PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture you've been
learning about applications
of integration.
And one of them
is how to compute
average values of a function.
So I have a nice average
value problem for you here.
So Christine was out jogging
one day and she saw a bear,
and so she broke into a sprint.
She starts speeding up,
and her velocity t seconds
after she started sprinting
is given by v of t
equals 1500 divided by
the quantity 100 plus
t minus 5 squared, the
whole thing minus 7.
And it's in meters per second.
So OK, so she starts
at t equals 0,
she's going 1500 divided by
125, so that's 12 minus 7,
so 5 meters per second.
And she starts to speed
up and after 5 seconds
she's going 1500
divided-- well this is 0--
so she's going 8 meters
per second at 5 seconds.
And then she looks
over her shoulder
and she sees, oh no,
it wasn't up a bear,
it was just an unkempt
math graduate student,
so then she starts
to slow down again.
She slows back down and
10 seconds later she's
back to her original velocity.
So the question is, over the
10 seconds of this sprint,
she sped up, she slowed
down, from 5 meters
per second to 8 meters per
second and then back to 5.
What was her average
velocity over this time?
So why don't you pause
the video, take some time
to work that out, come back
and we can work on it together.
So hopefully you had some
luck working on this problem.
I have over on my left here
a little picture of the graph
of this function v of t.
I described it to you
earlier, but just you
see, OK, so it starts at 5,
after 5 seconds it's at 8,
and then it goes back
down to 5 at 10 seconds.
So this is roughly
the picture, so we
have a feel for what
we're working with.
Now what we want to compute
is the average velocity
over this time.
So anytime you have to
compute an average value
of any function
what you want to do,
you always do the same thing.
So you want to compute the total
contribution of that function
over the interval in question.
So you want to add it up,
you want to integrate it
over the interval in question.
But then you want to divide
by the length of the integral.
So in particular, when you
have a velocity function what
that means is, you
integrate the velocity.
So that gives you the
total distance traveled,
and then you divide
by the time interval.
S you're just taking total
distance divided by total time.
So in this case we can write
down this average value.
So I'm going to use
just a made up notation.
I'm going to write avg, for
average, of v, so what is it?
Well the first
thing I have to do
is I want to not
forget to divide
by the length of
the interval here.
So in this case, the
interval is from 0 to 10,
so it has length 10
minus 0, which is 10.
So I want 1/10 in front and
what I want to multiply this by,
is I want to multiply
by the integral
over this entire interval
of my function v.
So I just take the formula that
I had over there for v and I
plop it down into my integral.
So it's the integral
from 0 to 10
of 1500 divided by 100 plus
t minus 5 quantity squared
minus 7 dt.
So this integral is the average
value that we're looking for.
OK.
So now we have to go
about evaluating it.
Now, this looks kind of ugly,
but actually it's not that bad.
I mean, one thing you can
notice, so the minus 7 part,
that's going to be
easy to take care of.
And then in this more
complicated part, well
there's a kind of obvious
substitution here.
You can set u equal
t minus 5, that'll
simplify it a little bit.
and then what you'll
see is that you
have an integrand of the
form something divided
by 100 plus u squared.
And so that's 10
squared plus u squared.
So that should keep-- and
the something as a constant.
So that should put you in the
mind of a tangent substitute,
or just even not
by substitution,
you can just
remember that that's
an arctangent type of thing
that you're going to get out.
so I'm not going to go through
all the steps of doing that,
but we should get at the end--
well OK, so I've got this 1/10
out in front, so I have
to not forget about that.
I get 1/10 times,
I've gone ahead
and I've computed
the anti-derivative
and it's 150 times arctan of
the quantity t minus 5 over 10.
So here's that t minus 5, that's
the same t minus 5 over there
that's coming out.
Minus 7t.
And you want to take that
between t equals 0 and t equals
10.
So this is, I've
just, I've gone ahead,
I've computed the
anti-derivative for us.
There's my 1/10 because
I'm doing an average value
and then I'm, it's
a definite integral
and so I'm using fundamental
theorem of calculus;
there are my bounds.
OK, so now we just have
to plug in and evaluate.
So this is equal
to, so let's see.
So we've got when we put in
t equals 10-- well the 1/10
and the 150 gives me a 15--
arctan of 1/2 minus-- well it's
1/10 of 7 times 10, it's just 7.
That's from the first one.
And from the second
one I guess minus--
so it's going to be 15
arctan of minus 1/2.
When I put in t equals 0,
and when I put in t equals 0,
the 7t is just 0.
OK.
This is a little messy.
We can simplify it a little bit,
because, remember arctangent is
an odd function.
So arctan of minus x is
minus arctangent of x.
So minus 15 arctan minus 1/2 is
the same as just 15 arctan 1/2.
And so we can combine those.
So we can rewrite that.
Let's go all the way over here.
We can rewrite this as
30 arctan 1/2 minus 7.
So that's about it as nice a
form as you can make this take.
If you wanted to plug
it into a calculator,
I think you'd see that this
is approximately equal to 6.9
and I guess the units there are
going to be meters per second.
So her average
velocity over this time
is about 6.9 meters per second.
Let's just quickly
recap what we did.
So we started all
the way back here
with this velocity
function v, and we
wanted to compute it's average
value over the interval 0
less than or equal to t,
less than or equal to 10.
So we did what we always do
in problems of that sort.
So we came over
here, and whenever
you want to compute
an average value,
you take 1 divided by the length
of the interval in question,
times-- then just you
integrate the function who's
average value you want
over the interval.
OK?
And so then we computed, well
we didn't show any of the steps,
but we computed the
definite integral
by taking the anti-derivative
and plugging in
and it happened that the answer
worked out to be about 6.9.
So there you go.
I'll stop there.